[Musique]
la première ministre elisabeth bornes
vient de faire entrer une yvelinoise au
gouvernement mais ce n'est pas la
première fois que cela arrive nadia et
faisait ses cartons il ya une semaine
nommé ministre délégué en charge de la
ville le 6 juillet 2020 elle avait été
élu député de la 11e circonscription des
yvelines en 2010 cet attrape sa ville de
naissance autres trappistes à rentrer au
gouvernement en 2012 sous la présidence
de françois hollande benoît hamon
devient ministre de l'économie sociale
et solidaire il est élu dans le même
temps député ps de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines mais doit
renoncer à son mandat en intégrant le
gouvernement en 2014 il est nommé
ministre de l'éducation nationale un
poste occupé environ quatre mois
puisqu'il décide de démissionner en août
2014 en désaccord avec les choix
politiques de françois hollande sous la
présidence de nicolas sarkozy et
plusieurs personnalités chinoises sont
devenus ministres comme valérie pécresse
elle devient en 2007 ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche puis ministre du budget des
comptes publics et de la réforme de
l'état christine boutin député des
yvelines entre 1986 et 2007 rentre
également dans le gouvernement fillon en
2007 en tant que ministre du logement
élu député ump des yvelines de la 12e
circonscription en 2009 david douillet
sacré plusieurs fois champion du monde
de judo est nommé ministre des sports en
2011 président actuel du sénat et ancien
maire de rambouillet gérard larcher a
été ministre délégué aux relations du
travail en 2004 sous le gouvernement de
jean pierre raffarin autres yvelinois
devenu secrétaire d'état chargé des
programmes immobiliers de la justice en
2002 pierre bédier actuel président du
département un peu plus loin dans le
temps michel rocard devient premier
ministre de françois mitterrand en juin
1988 il avait été élu député des
yvelines en 1969 en battant l'ex premier
ministre sortant maurice couve de
murville derniers premiers ministres
sous la présidence de charles de gaulle